so you got any weekend plans oh you know  gonna spend the whole weekend in bed my  boyfriend a few bottles of wine food if  we take a little bit to Klaus gonna be a  marathon  [Music]  oh gosh I gotta go no but the next  episode is about to start  it's an eight seven six based on your  interests in Parks and Recreation in 30  rock I got you this theme girls what do  you want to watch night ooh I've been  dying to watch Eternal Sunshine of the  spotless mind again oh that selection is  no longer available it was there last  week but you were always doing this to  me  [Music]  Perla bitchin you like commercials  though right  [Music]  welcome back I've got something I think  you'll like the 1998 Parent Trap  starting Lindsay Lohan mm-hmm I've  missed you  [Music]